so let me ask kind of an artificial
intelligence engineering question so
you've been an outspoken critic of I
guess what could be called intelligent
design which is an attempt to describe
the creation of a human mind a body by
some religious folks that really just
folks used to describe so broadly
speaking evolution is as far as I know
again you can correct me is the only
scientific theory we have for the
development of intelligent life like
there's no alternative theory as far as
as far as I understand none has ever
been suggested and I suspect it never
will be well of course one of the
somebody says that a hundred years later
I know it's a risk but um what a bet I
mean I'm what he would look sorry yes it
would probably look very similar but
it'd be it's almost like Einstein's
general relativity versus Newtonian
physics it'll be maybe an alteration of
the theory or something like that but it
won't be fundamentally different but
okay it so so now for the past 70 years
even before the a a committee has been
trying to engineer intelligence in a
sense to do what intelligent design says
the you know was done here on earth
what's your intuition do you think it's
possible to build intelligence to build
computers that are intelligent or do we
need to do something like the
evolutionary process like there's
there's no shortcuts here that's an
interesting question
i I'm committed to the belief that is
ultimately possible because I think
there's nothing non-physical in our
brains I think how our brains work by by
the laws of physics and so it must in
principle it be possible to replicate
that in practice though it might be very
difficult and as you suggest it might it
may be the only way to do it is by
something like an evolutionary process
I'd be surprised I suspect that it will
come but it's certainly been slower in
coming and some of the early pioneers I
thought I thought it would be yeah but
in your sons is the evolutionary process
efficient so you can see it as
exceptionally wasteful in one
perspective but at the same time maybe
that is the
only path is a paradox isn't it I mean
on the one side it is deplorable it
wasteful yeah
it's fundamentally based on waste on the
other hand it does produce magnificent
results when the the the design of a
soaring bird an albatross a vulture an
eagle is superb an engineer would be
proud to have done it on the other hand
an engineer would not be proud to have
done some of the other things that
evolution has served up some of the sort
of botched jobs that you can easily
understand because of their historical
origins but they don't look well
designed your examples bad design my
favorite example is there a current
laryngeal nerve I've used this many
times this is a nerve it's one of the
cranial nerves it goes from the brain
and the end organ is that it supplies is
the Voicebox the larynx but it doesn't
go straight to the layers it goes right
and done to the chest and then loops
around an artery in the chest and then
come straight back up again to the
larynx and I've assisted in the
dissection of a giraffe's neck which
haven't have died in a zoo and we
watched the we saw the recurrent
laryngeal nerve getting whizzing
straight past the larynx within an inch
of the larynx down into the chest and
then back up again which is a detour of
many feet very very inefficient the
reason is historical the ancestors are
fish ancestors the ancestors of all
mammals and fish the most direct pathway
of that of the equivalent of that nerve
there wasn't Alaric's in those days but
it innovated part of the gills the most
direct pathway was behind that artery
and then when the mammal when the
tetrapods were in the land vertebra
started ever evolving and then the next
started to stretch the marginal cost of
changing the embryo logical design to
jump that nerve over the artery was too
great or rather was was each step of the
way was of was a very small cost but the
marginal but the cost of actually
jumping it over would have been very
large as the neck lengthened it was a
negligee
we'll change to just increase the length
the length of the detour tiny bit a tiny
bit a tiny bit each millimeter timed in
making a difference and so but finally
when you get to a giraffe it's a huge
detour and no doubt is very inefficient
now that's bad design any engineer would
reject that piece of jade design is
ridiculous and there are quite a number
of examples as you would expect it's not
surprising let me find examples of that
sort in a way what's surprising is there
aren't more of them in a way what's
surprising is that the design of living
things is so good so natural selection
manages to achieve excellent results
partly by tinkering partly by coming
along and cleaning up initial mistakes
and in as it were making the best of a
bad job that's an interesting I mean
it's it is surprising and beautiful and
it's a it's a mystery from an
engineering perspective that so many
things are well designed I suppose the
thing we're forgetting is how many
generations have to die oh yeah four
that's the inefficiency of it yes that's
the horrible wastefulness of it so yeah
we we marvel at the final product but
yeah the process is painful
you